Every organ transplants save thousands of
lives, but what happens if your body rejects
the new organ?
Hey guys, Julia here for Dnews
The first successful liver transplant was
performed in 1954.
Since then the techniques have improved over
the years.
29,000 organ transplants are performed in
the United States every year.
But it’s a tricky business.
Matches are rare and rejection can get pretty
nasty.
And rejections happens more often than you
might think.
While some types of transplants are more successful,
like cornea transplants have a 75% success
rate over ten years and five-year organ survival
rates for heart, kidney and liver transplants
is about 70 percent.
But on the other hand, according to the National
Kidney Foundation, 17% of kidney transplants
fail within three years.
While the survival rate of lung transplants
is surprisingly low, like 66% after three
years according to report from the Children’s
Hospital of Pittsburgh.
When a person gets a new limb or organ, their
body obviously recognizes it as foreign.
and like most foreign things, it tries to
get rid of it.
So what happens when someone’s body rejects
a transplant?
There are three main kinds of rejection, hyperacute,
acute and chronic.
Hyperacute happens almost instantaneously,
within minutes or hours, the recipient's body
starts to reject the new organ or limb.
Acute rejection can occur within a few months
to a year from transplantation.
Chronic rejection can happen over a few years.
Basically, your body uses its immune system
to fight off any foreign invader, whether
that’s a virus or a new liver.
A hugely important part of the immune system
is the Major histocompatibility complex (MHC).
The MHC’s main job is to differentiate between
your body’s cells and not your body’s
cells.
The MHC is made up of mostly glycoproteins
on the walls of your cells.
They act as tags that say THIS IS ME.
When a white blood cell reads that tag, it’s
like okay cool, I won't destroy you.
There’s over 20 genes that code for the
MHC and over 50 variations PER GENE.
So there’s a lot of combinations.
I mean.
A LOT.
This is why it’s so hard to match a donor
to a recipient.
When the MHC recognizes the tags as foreign,
it starts a process that triggers destruction
of the weird scary unknown cells.
Your immune system produces T-Cells which
go in and target the foreign cells and induces
Apoptosis or programed cell death.
other cells and proteins get involved too,
like phagocytes which basically eat up the
dead cells.
Anyways it’s a messy process.
You can tell your body is rejecting an organ
in a few ways, swelling or redness, generally
feeling ill and specific kinds of organ failure.
But there are ways to beat rejection.
Most of it involves immunosuppressive drugs,
which can include corticosteroids such as
prednisone.
While right after the transplant, the dose
of medication is pretty high, but doctors
might ween the dose over the course of a year
to a "maintenance phase".
But the thing is, most people have to be on
the medication for life, sometimes up to 12
different medications every day.
And because the drugs lower their immune system,
they put themselves at risk for infections,
illnesses, and even certain types of cancer.
They have to forever walk a fine line between
rejection and infection.
But research is being done to try to remove
the need for such drugs.
Some recent research from UCSF holds some
promise.
In a study published in American Journal of
Transplantation the researchers used a two-tiered
approach to tackle rejection.
First they administered a drug called cyclophosphamide
to mice which had transplanted tissues.
The drug effectively killed off most of those
T-cells I mentioned earlier.
Then the mice received cell therapy which
grew populations of certain cells called TREGs,
and like that name suggests they regulate
T cells.
And with more of these cells in place, they
hold back the immune system from rejecting
the organ or limb.
According to the study nearly 80% of the mice
accepted a transplant without the need for
a lifelong regimen of drugs!
And this technique proved successful in one
patient already!
So that could be pretty cool one day.
But it’s clear more research is needed.
Changing gears for a second, NASA is about
to fly-by Pluto and we're doing a live Google
Hangout with our space producer Ian O'Neill
and a special guest INSIDE MISSION CONTROL.
It's going to be awesome.
Come join on July 14 at 1pm Pacific 4pm Eastern
and RSVP on the event page for a reminder!
Theres a link in the description too!